[Music]
let's go to sabrina out in buffalo new
york hey sabrina what's going on
hi um i'm a senior in college and my
boyfriend's also a senior in college and
i guess two weeks ago we found out that
i am pregnant and last week i got
proposed to
and um we're kind of just wondering how
do we take care of our baby while we're
still graduating
and um how we like get started in
marriage
i was just telling somebody before the
show came on sabrina
that i've had a chaotic last few weeks
and i am going to retract that statement
100
so you're having a baby congratulations
and he proposed to you you don't sound
super excited tell me about that
oh i am i'm just i'm still kind of in
shock over the whole thing yeah i can
imagine so
um
so what are you studying like
um i'm studying computer science
computer science okay and what's your
i guess did you say yes
oh yeah we said yes we're getting
married in december i'm super excited i
like um i plan on marrying like two
years from now just not now if that
makes sense
it makes total sense and
so
what's your fiance gonna do
um he's gonna be mechanical engineer um
we're super lucky because we kind of
both have job offers i mean i'm still
looking for the current offer i have i'm
gonna be making 130 and then he'll be
making 90s yeah outstanding outstanding
okay so drill down your question for me
you graduate you're a senior so you're
gonna graduate um in may is that right
yeah both of us are okay
um
and are you gonna be able to navigate
your final trimesters in school and
what's your what's your spring semester
gonna look like um i was really lucky i
only have two classes left but because
of financial aid i'm gonna have to take
12 credits so i was just going to take
the easiest classes i need to graduate
cool
so i
in that very seat as a dean of students
at several colleges i worked with
students in your situation
and so what i would recommend you do
is to go meet with the school health
clinic go meet with the dean of students
office whoever that that person would be
that would walk you through that
let them know
and um make sure everybody's on the same
page just your college resources you're
paying a bajillion dollars for those
resources so this is a great moment to
put those to use
um and you're gonna get y'all get
married pretty quick right you're
getting married in just a few months
here in
december yeah
just because um we didn't want to be
married right when the baby was about to
pop out
[Laughter]
those are your words not mine i wouldn't
have said that but cool i'll let you
have that one um so
tell me distill your question down for
me it sounds like you are just
it sounds like you were skiing and then
the skis float from under you but you
didn't let go of the rope and you just
get that face full of water for about
250 yards before you finally let go and
now you're bobbing in the water and
everything is like whoa everything's
changed
do you have a particular question or you
just want someone to walk alongside you
and say
we're rooting for you and you guys are
going to be doing great financially
um
you're going to be if you make some wise
choices financially now make some wise
choices on
we this is happening two years early
everything got accelerated but we're
going to be highly connected we're going
to get some premarital counseling we're
going to make sure we're on the same
page both how we're going to raise this
baby how we're going to love this baby
where we're going to live
and start to the word i want to to
infuse in your soul here is intentional
you're a computer scientist you're
married an engineer you all
intentionally build things i want you to
take that level of intentionality to
your relationship that's just been put
in hyperdrive
um but beyond that do you have a
specific question that we can help with
or just want us to cheer you on here
um i think so i think both of us we're
gonna be graduating with i think 30
thousand dollars of debt combined and we
were kind of just wondering um
if we should probably like what we i
guess like financially what we should do
in order to pay off this debt because
should we pay off this bit immediately
or should we wait until we're kind of
settled and what exactly should we be
doing
yeah
george can hop in here with with walking
through the baby steps but absolutely
you're going to want to get this thing
out of your life as soon as possible
you're going to want to enter into this
new
season of your life as a wife as a mom
as a brand new
computer scientist you're going to want
to walk through that life with this few
strings or attachments to
to um uh
other people as possible and yes knock
that dead out george walker through the
baby steps so what we talk about with
the baby steps and baby step 2 you're
paying off all of your consumer debt but
because of the baby on the way we talk
about going in storm and stork mode john
so i want you to not pay off that debt
until the baby's here and baby's healthy
and you're healthy and everyone's doing
good and whatever pile of cash you have
then you can throw that on the debt and
with this income it's going to be gone
within a few months
after the baby's here regardless so do
you guys have any income right now are
you just full-time students
um i mean we work like when we work like
i guess not minimum wage jobs but like
slightly more than that just to pay a
rent because like both of us are on like
basically full financial aid so like
whatever
but we have to pay for like rent and
food and stuff okay and you're not going
into any more debt before you graduate
um like whatever like i cannot make this
year because of pregnancy if that makes
sense because like i don't know how much
money like i probably won't be able to
work next semester if that makes sense
yeah well as much as you can avoid going
into more debt that's going to be super
helpful as part of this process as you
bring a baby into this world and really
start your own your adult life a little
earlier than you might have planned so i
would suck up as much money as you can
until baby's here and if baby's healthy
and you've got that money sitting there
you can throw that on the debt but
either way you need to get really
focused on this debt because i want you
to focus on being great parents and
being great adults and not have this
other stress in your life if we got to
make payments to lenders
yeah
here's what we're going to do i'm going
to sabrina we're gonna give you um i was
gonna say i am but george is here too so
we are we're gonna give you as a baby
gift we're gonna give you a year's
subscription to ramsey plus
and i want you and your fiance
in the next few months i want you all to
sit down and watch all of the financial
peace university lessons
i want you to walk through it together
and create an intentional plan about
what life is going to look like next
semester
what life is going to look like a year
from now where y'all might want to live
you've got job offers in hand which as
george said are phenomenal offers
the way forward right now is a is a cold
water dose of reality a cold water dose
of
planning and high high intentionality
and then by the way when this baby comes
everything you think you've planned is
going to go it's going to blow up right
babies will do that to you and your
life's going to change in dramatic
fashion so the intentionality stuff you
can do up front so stay on the line and
kelly's going to get you a copy of that
i mean it's going to get you a year
subscription there